- What up vlog.
Working out with Jordan this morning,
here on the West Coast.
Anyway, on today's DailyVee,
we go into to a keynote
I did with Chase Jarvis at
kind of a photography summit.
Obviously, the world of photography
has been struck tremendously
over the last decade
and this talk, I think,
covers a ton of that.
So for your creative friends,
make sure they listen to this.
Hope you enjoy.
(rock music)
- Hello.
Say hi to your neighbor for a second.
You guys look all scared.
Introduce yourself.
All right.
(laughs)
(imitating smooching)
All right, I'm gonna start
it off since, I guess,
I've been a part of the photo industry
for as long as I can remember.
I think it's really
important to understand
that craft plays a really important role
in the life that you
all have chosen to lead.
You have to be good at it, but
just like professional golf,
say there's 300 people
who play in the PGA.
You can only name two or three
and everything beyond craft
is what will help you.
You have to have craft to get in the door,
but if you don't have all the other stuff,
it's going to be very
hard to make the living,
and more importantly,
the life that you want.
We are co-keynoting today,
in part because I
realized over my career...
The first time I came
here, I showed pictures.
The second time I came here,
I showed pictures and told stories.
The third time I came here, on this stage,
the third time I keynoted,
I showed pictures and videos
and told stories and
talked about social media.
The fourth time I came
here, I've been here a lot.
(audience laughs)
Fourth time I came here, it was
all about outside influences
and all the first one through five,
I feel like got picked up and absorbed
and internalized from
the hundreds of folks
who are sitting in the audience today
and the thousands of people
who are watching these videos
after we post them.
But what has not been internalized
is that the best information,
influence, ideas, strategies,
creative inspiration comes
from outside the industry.
It comes from outside.
If you're all looking at
the person next to you
for inspiration and they're
looking to you, what happens?
It's just a circle and I've seen that.
I'm thinking of my life
mission with CreativeLive,
with my show, Chase
Jarvis Live, and in part,
by hanging around with
people like Gary and others,
to bring that inspiration
into our industry.
I feel like it's the number
one thing that's ignored
and this particular human has
had a huge influence on me,
on popular culture in general,
and so I thought it'd be good
if the biggest service
that I could be of service
in this community would be
to let you hear from someone
who wouldn't normally
be here at this place.
So with that, I'm gonna
give you a question.
We're in conversation.
This is the longest you've
been quiet, probably.
(audience laughs)
- I'm literally bleeding inside my mouth
'cause I'm biting my tongue so hard.
That was super hard, whew!
- Give some introduction of--
- Can I actually say
something before the question?
- Please, yes.
First of all, I'm very,
very humbled and flattered
to be here in this community.
I think all subcommunities
are super fascinating.
They have their own DNA,
their own beating heart.
I have had the luxury
in the last seven years,
to build a creative agency.
VaynerMedia has 300
creatives that work for us
across many different offices,
and the thing that I've
been most fascinated by
is the thing that connects all of us,
regardless if we're in this industry,
entrepreneurs, traders,
mothers and parents,
piano players or traders on Wall Street.
Whatever it is.
What has been very fascinating to me,
in this space, is ego.
Ego is a killer.
You know, I've been really thinking about
coming here this morning and I was like,
I really want to bring value.
I hope I say something
that really helps somebody.
And when things change,
and we're living in a very changing world.
A lot of our contemporaries,
maybe the people you looked up to
or your grandparents that
also did this kind of work,
creative work, they had
a strength or a weakness.
A luxury or an issue,
depending on how you look at the world.
Their world stayed firm
and stable for a long time.
We do not have that luxury.
We're living during a great revolution.
It's called the internet.
It's now 20 years old on the consumer side
and it is the biggest shift to our culture
on a human level, let
alone on a creative level.
And what it's done is the following.
It's eliminated gatekeepers.
The internet is the middle man.
So, if I could leave
you with with anything,
I genuinely believe the thing
that has helped me be
successful in my trade
is that I deploy unbelievable
amounts of humility
for all my cockiness around one thing.
The market is the judge
and the jury, not me.
And I think that in the creative field,
the thing that has hurt so
many people I care about
is they want to rest
on experience or awards
that are arbitrary, by the way,
or degrees or something
other than the market.
You may not like it, but
the market always chooses.
- So, if I'm gonna pick up
on that thread for a second,
I think that's part of
what I meant in what was...
When I would speak,
what would be absorbed.
And I think there's also
this dramatic hesitation
that a lot of people say I can't do this.
I'm not this.
There's some punk who's 17
years old, with a camera,
and she's gonna kick my ass
and you're giving away trade secrets
and it's unfair and I
think, as photographers,
and I came into the
industry a long time ago,
it was very much closed.
It was about secrets, and
I'm not gonna bring in
an assistant because
they're gonna learn from me
and they're gonna learn
my special lighting stuff
and then they're gonna go out
and they're gonna use that
against me to take money.
I've literally had death threats
and I'm not trying to
overdramatize it, but--
- Well, you're a pretty bad guy.
(audience laughs)
I'm just kidding.
- From people who have
said that I'm taking money
by CreativeLive, we've given
away three or four billion
minutes of free education.
- The internet has given away way more.
- Yes, for sure.
- I don't understand
what people are debating.
Information has been commoditized.
You have to wrap your head around it.
You're more than welcome
to live in your own head
and create excuses.
The problem is nobody gives a fuck.
(audience laughs)
It is what it is.
I wish that Email didn't
become not as popular.
I built my first business on it.
I wish that Twitter was still number one.
I was one of the first people
with a million followers.
I wish, I wish, I wish.
The only reason that
I have the great honor
to sit on this stage right now
is 'cause I give away all my best advice,
for free, every single day.
- [Woman] Thank you!
- You're welcome.
(audience laughs)
You're welcome, and let me
tell you a couple things
that you may find unbelievably powerful,
and it may be a shift,
and I speak to somebody
in their 40's, like me, 50's, 60's, 70's
because your habits are formed.
Let me say something that
might be a huge unlock.
99% of people don't do anything
about the free information.
The reason I give away all my best stuff
is 'cause nobody does anything about it,
which leaves plenty for me to still do.
- And for the 1% that do,
those become your new friends.
Those are your peers
or the people you love.
- Let me tell you one
other thing about those 1%.
They were gonna win anyway.
You can't stop winners
from winning, my friends.
And then you can educate the other 99%
and get all the admiration
and leave a wonderful legacy
and live a fulfilled life.
That's the model.
- As the owner of a creative
agency, I want to shift gears.
Specifically, you work with a
lot of people who create media
and what is your number
one piece of advice,
besides being grateful
and besides making sure
that you understand that
the market is right.
What is a tactic that you
feel like this audience,
by and large, is getting wrong?
- Be in the yes business.
Be in the yes business.
Instagram, yes.
Filters, yes.
Going live, yes.
Snapchat, yes.
TPH, yes.
VR, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Why are you so fancy with your time?
Like, really?
You don't have time for this,
but yet, you have the
ambition to get the luxuries
that come along with being independent?
We do not map our actions to our mouths.
If you have aspirations
to win, to crush it,
to do it the way you want to do it,
you need to be in the yes business.
I, at this point, have
achieved enormous things
and every day I deploy
humility to download a new app
and taste it, and waste my time
because I know I learn every time.
I know the market's
moving, and I'm stunned
by how many creatives master a skill
and then try to milk it for 47 years.
That's not the reality that we're doing.
And so, you need to be
in the yes business.
Yet, I see creatives always saying no
and they come up with
some arbitrary bullshit
of why it's not pure and
then they get run over.
- So, little bit about the format.
If you're thinking that some of this
might be resonating
with you, at some point
in the next, I have no
idea how much time we have.
We could talk all day.
I think you guys know us.
- At some point--
- How much?
- Yeah, how much?
- 40 minutes.
- What?
- 40.
- 40, okay right now, some
of you are going like,
"Oh shit, 40 more minutes of this."
(audience laughs)
- Hopefully--
- If you've done that, you've lost.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, that's exactly that I
don't got time for this thing.
This seat right here is
reserved for a couple of people
that would like actual
information from he and I,
one on one in real time.
So if you think you have a problem
that you would like to have solved,
I would like, I'm gonna
do a couple of these
throughout the 40 minutes here.
So I would like one person,
I'll let Gary pick them.
- I already invited him.
- Fuckin' A, we got it right here.
(audience claps)
Right on.
How you doing, bud?
- How are you?
- I'm doing great.
- Great to meet you.
- Oh my god.
(speaking faintly)
(laughing)
- We gotta get this gentleman
a microphone, if we can.
While we're finding a mic for you,
I'll talk slowly so we can get you a mic.
I see it coming.
You're up here not just to hang out.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- You're up here because,
what I believe is about 100 problems
that we all have.
As humans, we all have about 100 problems,
and they can be in
various different camps,
but we're gonna try-
We got time for that shit later.
(audience laughs)
- I'll record, I'll record it.
- Oh my god.
- There you go.
(audience laughs)
- But what we're gonna do...
They'll turn it on, just talk.
- Can't figure it out, okay great.
- Let me here.
It's on.
Hold it close to your face.
- Let's start with your name.
- Hello, I'm Jason McCoy
from Jason McCoy Photography,
in Chicago, Illinois.
- Give it up for Jason.
- Let's give it up for Jason!
(audience cheers)
- Jason, welcome.
What's your biggest challenge right now?
- I think my biggest challenge now is
- I'm sorta--
- Being handsome!
(audience laughs)
- They call me sexy chocolate.
No, my biggest challenge now
is trading money for time.
So I don't have a problem
getting people in my studio.
Now, it's like, okay, I only
can do, maybe two shoots a day.
I want to make more money, but
I'm maxing out on just time.
I don't want to work 24/7.
- Raise your prices.
- 10x your prices tomorrow.
I'm serious as a heart attack.
If you 10x your rates, try it, 10x.
I say this on the internet
about twice a week.
I get pages from people
who are like, "holy shit.
"I 10x'ed my rates and I'm still busy."
They literally 10x their income.
- And here's the good part for everybody.
If nobody's paying, that
means the market's answering,
but guess what?
You know what's better
than the same rates?
Two extra rates.
Maybe you couldn't get the 10.
Maybe your market wasn't there.
Maybe your location wasn't there.
Maybe your talent wasn't there.
Maybe your brand wasn't there.
But you know what's better than a dollar?
Two dollars.
- Let me ask another question.
So, why do you charge
today what you charge?
Where did you get that information?
- Where did I get that information.
So, I have reviewed other
photographers that are in my area,
and then, I pretty much
reviewed other photographers
that were in my area.
I don't do commercial work.
I do strictly portraits.
And my price, where some
people are saying...
Some people say it's too high.
Other people say, oh
it was just this much,
so I'm in a middle, a
weird field right now.
- Can I ask you a question, Jason?
- Yeah.
- How many of the people
that said it was too high
still did it?
20%, 10%, 50%?
- I have people say, "you know,
I saved up for this shoot,
"so this means a lot
for me to come in here."
I've had that, so I don't know how...
- I understand.
- I had that situation.
- I want every person to be
right on the edge of saying no,
and just deciding to say
yes because you're worth it.
And if you can't figure out
what that sweet price is.
I don't have a price.
I don't say my rates are $250.
In some industries you should.
I always want to find out what
the upper limit of my client
and what they are going to value me.
If you're a $500 photographer,
you will always be a $500 photographer,
and for the client that
says you're gonna be,
"oh when I get more
money, I'll come back."
Bullshit.
Because when they find $5,000,
are they gonna go to a $500 photographer?
No fucking way.
They're gonna go to the
person who is 10 grand
and they'll try and talk
them into doing it for five.
- Jason.
I apologize, go ahead.
- Get in there, get in there.
- I just wanted to say to
you and everybody else,
never say no for the other guy.
- I don't know what that means.
- I'll explain it.
(audience laughs)
- It sounded good, though.
- It did sound good, right Jason?
- [Chase] It sounded good.
- That's why I went
with the dramatic pause.
Here's what I mean by that.
A lot of people talk themselves
out of a higher price.
I can't be $800, 'cause Rick,
who I think is better, is 650.
That means you're saying
no for the other person.
Keep pushing the envelope.
Let some people say no.
Listen, almost everything's
about supply and demand.
You don't know what your demand cost is
until you push the envelope.
The way I learned my price in speaking,
when I started getting
put on in 2009 and '10.
- Our story's the same on that one.
- I just kept asking for more every time
and when I got 11 no's
in a row for 50,000,
I'm like I guess I'm 40,000.
(audience laughs)
but that was a lot more than the 5,000
that I was thrilled to
get for a speech, right?
It is detrimental to
not continue to ask more
every single time and just keep going on.
Here's the funny part.
(imitates phone ringing)
Hello, it's Jason.
How much is it?
800.
Oh, that's too much.
700.
You're just playing a game of chicken.
Going higher, even if they
start seeing you're coming down,
you can eventually say no too.
You're so in control, yet it's insecurity
that's driving down your price.
- I think that's brilliant.
I gotta hop on the backside of that
and say are all of these clients
the same amount good for you?
- No, some suck.
- Oh, that's interesting.
- Some suck.
So when the ones that suck
call back at that shitty price
that you're charging, that's
the one where you say,
"oh, man, sorry, my rates have doubled.
"I'm super busy.
"I really appreciate you."
You don't say F off.
You say, oh I'm so busy.
I'm sorry, my rates are
double, and 10% of those people
are gonna go, "okay I still need it."
And you're like okay.
That client is becoming an okay client.
- It's the happiness cash ratio.
- Well, question then.
I have clients of various financial means.
So, if I have a client who's a millionaire
versus a client who
barely can afford this,
shouldn't I give equal
rates to everyone or no?
- First of all--
- No.
(audience laughs)
- No?
- Oh, wow, okay.
- Jason, Jason.
- And the answer is shouldn't
you according to who?
Who's the judge and the
jury of this shouldn't you?
If you want to-
by the way, I say yes.
I've lived my life by
giving different prices
based on people's financial situation
'cause it just makes me feel good.
By the way, I don't think you're wrong.
I'm asking everybody based on what?
Based on somebody else's opinion?
- That's why I ask him where
he got his information.
Where did he get his pricing information?
He got it from the market.
He looked around and said
I'm just like everybody else.
If Tommy's 10 and I'm
two, and Sally's two,
then I'm right here in the middle.
- Jason, if you want to be
Robin Hood, and charge 4x
for people that you think are rich,
so that you can do right by
certain other people, mazel tov.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
- Hey, let's give it
up for him, okay guys?
- Give it up.
(audience claps)
Chase, stand up.
- Wait, make sure you're in there.
- We should turn around,
actually, with the crowd.
- No, this is good, oh good idea.
Let's get the crowd.
- I'm a professional photographer.
- Yeah, I have no idea
what the fuck I'm doing.
(audience laughs)
- Awesome.
- Awesome, thank you guys.
- You're welcome.
- One more round of
applause for him, y'all.
Thank you.
(audience claps)
- We're gonna hold on just one second.
So, the plan here is actual value,
and what I loved about
that is raise your hand
if you have had a pricing
thought in your brain
that confused you just like that.
- Of course.
- That's 90% of the room?
- And 10% liars.
(audience laughs)
- All right.
Give us another framework
for how you're thinking,
that you see folks in
the creative community
is not thinking, Gary.
- Attention arbitrage.
So if I can have you leave
with anything about--
- Arbitrage is a bank thing.
They don't understand it.
- Understood.
- I'm not saying you,
like we as an industry
- Good news, I don't
understand arbitrage, the word,
either, but I know what I'm trying to say.
- I'm just trying be
like let's keep it real.
Let's not use big words.
(audience laughs)
- I failed every english
class I took, so I'm proud
that I get the token as a big word user.
Very simple.
There's overpriced and
underpriced attention.
As a collective of the
human race, right now,
there are places where people perceive
a lot of people are paying
attention to, and they're not.
Television commercials.
Print advertising.
Print other things.
And there's underpriced attention
that we haven't wrapped our head around,
even big things like Facebook
and Instagram and influencers.
So I think a lot of creatives
aren't being strategic enough
about building up their brand
or awareness for what they do
by creating work in places
where people are actually paying attention
versus what they grew up
putting on a pedestal.
I'd much rather, and by the
way, this is not even close.
I would much rather be on Chase's show
than interviewed in the
Wall Street Journal.
It's not even close.
That's fucking crazy, right?
- Thanks, Gary.
- You're welcome.
(audience laughs)
If you want to sell
something, you're far...
I could be on CNBC, CNN,
Fox, and the Today Show
and I would sell 10 times x my awareness
of whatever I was talking about
than if I just did Malcolm
Gladwell's podcast.
There's an amazing arbitrage, a shift,
an amazing dynamic, of the attention.
And listen, I get cumbered
by print New York Times,
and then some kid puts a
photo of me on Instagram.
I'm living it.
I know what's going on.
The attention has shifted
on you at a level-
and when I say you,
I don't mean the
photography creative sector.
I mean us humans.
The attention has shifted so quickly,
so extremely that if
you're a practitioner,
if you start thinking
about where it really is,
an amazing unlock for
the things that you want
for you and your family
comes from that world
and I'll piggyback on that.
This is very important to me.
You may not know what that means.
You're a creative.
You're an artist.
But it's scary to me that
you could spend five hours
on YouTube and Google searching things,
based on what I just said,
and get educated in five hours
that can disproportionately
change your life.
When people ae like I don't get it.
I'm like, cool.
Go google what's happening on Facebook.
How do I get more people
to pay attention to me
on Instagram?
The information is free.
You don't have to go to a fucking library.
You could do it in your
underpants at 2 a.m. in your bed
and it disproportionately
can change your life.
We are so blessed and so
lucky and people are choosing
pessimism over optimism and it baffles me.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
(audience claps)
- Yes.
- You're welcome.
- How 'bout you?
Let's reverse it.
As somebody who has deep
contacts into this community,
give me the last six months,
from your perspective,
as a thought leader, as a
practitioner of the craft.
Let's make it very narrow.
I'm gonna buy you a few more seconds here.
In the last six months, what's
been an interesting trend?
What's a meme?
What's a subculture?
What's happening?
- What's happening is the
industry is polarizing.
So, there's more photographs being bought
and sold now than ever before.
- Amazing.
- Two or three billion photos
get uploaded every day.
The photographers sitting
in this room think
that the industry is sinking.
The reality is there's more people buying.
There's more money in the
industry now than ever before
and people don't understand it.
They don't know it.
So what's happening is
the middle is falling out.
If you're beige or you're
gray or you're in the middle,
nobody fucking cares.
So you either want to be
down here in the market
doing high volume with a lot of stuff
and doing thousand dollar influencer shit
with your Instagram and you
can print money that way
or you're super high end,
working for the people who are,
if you're trusted, you've been
in this business a long time
and you can disproportionately
prove that you can do it,
because when someone hires
you, they're signing up.
It's on their ass and if
you can live in that camp,
you can print money, and
if you're in the middle,
trying to do the same
shit you did six months
or six weeks or two years ago,
you're gonna get eaten alive.
And it's now, and the last six months,
it used to be going like this and now it's
and anything in here, this is
beige and gray and people...
I prescribe being
different, not just better.
So this is a sea of the same.
You gotta do this with intention.
Don't just say I don't know who I am.
I don't know what I stand for.
I don't know who my customers are.
Figure it out and overindex on that.
- If you feel like you're in the gray,
I've got a little tactical
thing that might help you.
When this happens in markets,
and this is a classic business
thing that always happens.
It's why you're gonna see so
many of your favorite retail
stores go out of business
over the next five years.
Toys R Us and Lord and
Taylor's is the preview.
Literally 90% of the retailers
you know are gonna be out
in the next 10 years because
eCommerce got big enough
that it all broke and
that's what's happened
with the supply and demand of photography.
Here's an incredibly
optimistic thing to do.
This is exactly the moment
for you to take a step back,
if you feel you're in the
beige, or you're vulnerable,
I've got something really fun.
Take a step back and become
a super narrow niche expert
in a certain genre, A.K.A.
1980 to 1984 Smurf dynamics.
(audience laughs)
And this is gonna be really fun,
'cause if you love your craft,
and you have other interests,
this is where you get
real, real, real narrow.
Let me give you some of the super weird.
I take photos of high
school wide receivers.
Now, that is narrow.
But you have to understand
why it's powerful.
On the human psychology, most parents
think their kids in high
school that played football
are gonna play in the NFL.
They're delirious, right?
Which means it's a huge market.
And I know how narrow that is,
but if you love high school football,
if you live in Texas and it's religion,
you will find unbelievable
opportunity when you react
to expansion, you have to contract.
What's amazing is you can contract
in something you've always loved.
Tea.
You love tea.
Go deep into tea.
Take a photo of every tea leaf ever,
from every fucking angle ever.
(audience laughs)
I'm telling you, I'm telling you.
I've seen this over and over.
This is true pattern recognition.
This is not my intuition.
This could be an
incredible keynote for you
because you're gonna win twice.
You get to be fruitful in your craft
and you get to do it around the thing
that you most narrowly love.
- Spoken.
(audience claps)
- It's interesting.
And maybe you hate Instagram today,
but Instagram could help you
so much because what you can do
is you can start taking
three photos a day,
posting on Instagram and using
10, 15 hashtags around tea,
chamomile, black tea, samavor.
You can do it and people
will start discovering you
and then if you actually put in work
to actually make your life
happen and spend another hour
going to all the other tea
photos and adding your two cents,
commenting, becoming
part of the community,
you will be baffled by what will happen.
All of a sudden, in a six month period,
you've got 11 different
tea companies asking you
to take the official shot
that they're putting on their package,
then one of them becomes a big tea brand
and you get to live the rest of your life
walking around and seeing your picture.
I mean this is real, what I'm telling you,
and notice how interesting it is.
I know you clapped and you
really caught my attention.
I appreciate it.
This is where optimism beats pessimism.
Woe is me.
All these fuckfaces with a fucking iPhone
have taken everything away from me.
(audience laughs)
or holy shit, I can take
photos of cocker spaniels
for the rest of my fucking life.
(audience laughs)
That is binary.
(audience claps)
- All right, should we
do another hot seat?
- Yeah.
- All right, you can call on it, Gary.
- All right, that lovely lady right there.
(audience laughs)
- Time is short.
Hustle up, we got this.
Come on.
Welcome her to the stage, you guys.
Come on, let's go.
(crowd claps)
I have a gift for you.
- [Woman] Oh, thank you so much.
- Tell us who you are.
- Welcome.
- My name is Nicki, hi.
- Put that thing right up there.
- Yeah, I know, but I'm
giving this to Gary.
- Sure, here we go.
Now we've got a trend.
(audience laughs)
- I'm the least capable photographer
in this whole fucking place,
(audience laughs)
and I'm taking the video.
Let's do it.
- Okay, my name is Nicki.
I am a West Milford-based, New Jersey.
- Jersey in the house.
- Jersey in the house!
(audience cheers)
We are the same age and
I grew up in Old Bridge.
- You're 29?
- Right down the street.
- I know, don't I look great?
(laughs)
I'm really glad that I
got asked to be up here
after that exact question
because this is what I have done.
In the last six months,
I went super narrow.
I am now a yoga portrait photographer.
- Love it.
- Boom.
(audience claps)
- How's business?
- I would call that narrow.
Super narrow is I take photos of people
with curly blond hair that do yoga.
(Nicki laughing)
I'm just telling you.
I'm not kidding.
But go ahead.
- It's predominantly been women.
- Of course, I've heard.
- Great.
- What I have done, because you said
that nobody listens to you (laughing).
I pretty much dropped out
doing my portrait business
I still pick it up if people call me,
but I'm not pursuing it.
- [Gary] Are you charging more now?
- Well this is where I'm at.
- Mistake.
- This is where I'm at because I decided
about a year ago today
that, from reading 10X,
that I wanted to do 500 shoots in one year
and I did shoot 372 this morning.
- Awesome.
- Do the work.
(audience claps)
- You better hurry the fuck up
because you're running behind.
- (laughing) yeah.
- I mean it's almost
November, 372, she's behind.
- I am, I am definitely running behind.
I punted a few weeks.
- You better fucking
get your act together.
And it's the holidays.
Fucking Thanksgiving, that week is shot.
- Last two weeks are fucked.
- It's gonna be tough.
- Exactly.
- You better fucking hustle.
- No freebies up here.
No freebies.
- Well, that was the problem.
I have been doing freebies.
I've been reaching out,
which is another thing.
I'm selling shit on eBay,
so that I can keep the money rolling in.
And I am reaching out
to people on Instagram,
saying I'll shoot you for free.
I'll shoot you for free.
- [Gary] It's happening on the DM.
Going down, keep on sliding in.
- This morning's shoot,
she has 49,000 followers.
- So the thing is...
- The question is...
- Now...
- Chase is about to punch you.
- [Gary] You need to get to the question.
- (laughs) no, I love you.
- I know, I'm sorry.
- No, you're great.
- That's okay.
- When do I start saying fuck you pay me?
- Hold tight.
- Tomorrow.
- Yeah, yeah, I would say
tomorrow, but here's the thing.
If you're busy doing that thing,
you should start charging
for it immediately.
What else I heard in there,
and this is the thing
that most of your, having
been in your shoes,
I know that what you're
saying right now is
yeah, but I make 95% of
my money off weddings.
Should I just shut down
my wedding business?
Nope, and there's a lot of
heads nodding out there,
'cause I wanna do this thing.
- I wanna get known for--
- No.
- I wanna get paid for this thing.
- Yeah, exactly.
I am taking money-
I photographed a preschool last week.
I still have the stuff on the side.
I'm not posting that on my Instagram page
because it is specifically for the yoga.
- Perfect.
- That's the key right there.
She's not showing pictures of things
she doesn't want to get hired to shoot.
- I have other accounts.
I have an account that I have
my travel photography on.
- She's selling in one place.
She's branding in another.
- Right.
But my thing is, I'm reaching
out to all these people,
they're finally saying yes,
but now I'm feeling like
I'm starting to get used.
- No, no, no, you're using them.
Be careful.
- This is where it's chasing my head.
- You're using them.
You had an agenda.
You had an ambition.
You're trying to build brand.
So you reached out to them.
You're using them.
Until you say there's a price to it,
they're not taking advantage of you.
They're saying yes to you
taking advantage of them.
- Well, now they call me--
- You know how many people
reach out to me like Gary,
I'll shoot you, I'll do this.
You're gonna leverage my
brand to build your business
and that makes me happy.
But I'm not taking advantage of you.
- Well, no because now there's companies
that are saying, all right
well... 'cause I was thinking
maybe there's a commercial aspect of it.
So I'll get a yoga
company to send me stuff
or they'll send the model
stuff and I'll photograph them
and then I'll be like, okay, well,
can I work on the next
campaign or I want to do this
and they're like, "no, we
just want your images."
- so that's where that whole--
- Can I tell you something?
- Go ahead.
- You're in control.
When the yoga company hits you up and says
we'd like to send you a yoga
mat to use in this next thing,
you say cool, $1,000.
And when they say fuck you,
you move on to the next one.
- That's what I've been doing.
- Good.
- It's gotten to that point.
- Mazel tov.
- This is the thing, though.
How scared are you that
you're never gonna make money?
- Very.
- Right.
Anybody else out there ever been scared?
Do you understand we're
all in this shit together.
Her psychology, her challenges are yours,
so if you're not paying attention right-
that's literally the
function of this thing
- we're doing right here.
- Feel like Q & A's the best.
- What's that?
- I feel like Q and A's the best.
- I want you to know that
you have, I hear ambiguity.
You don't know how you're gonna get money.
- I don't.
- Exactly.
- And I've been talking
to a couple of my friends
- and I'm like what do I--
- we're here.
(audience laughs)
- We're gonna help.
We're gonna help.
- But here's something more
important than us being here.
We're about to leave.
(audience laughs)
- and so the key is--
- I'm about to go home to two kids.
- Correct.
And it's gonna be Tuesday.
And it was nice that you were on the stage
with Gary and Chase, but now
it's fuck, what do I do now?
It's very simple.
This shit is binary.
Either you ask for money or you don't.
- I literally came here to ask you that,
because I've been doing it
and doing it and doing it
and I'm like, okay, but...
Okay, I get the patience thing.
The patience thing took
a very, very long time.
- Can I say something?
The person that can hold
their breath the longest wins.
So if you can afford to
keep doing nursery school
and shursery school and all
that for three or four years,
you're gonna continue to build
brand and have more leverage.
- Don't light your other business on fire.
Just don't talk about it all that much.
- Right.
- Sales and branding.
- You're building something over here.
You're simmering your shit over here.
I don't care if this is a full time job
or it's shooting weddings or whatever.
You want to shoot automotive,
you want to shoot women in yoga pants.
I get it.
- Let's talk about a year from now.
- I'm serious!
That is the thing.
You have to be intentional.
My biggest fear is I stand
up to thousands of people
eyeball to eyeball.
People don't actually know what they want
or if they know what they
want, they're afraid to say it.
When we leave here today,
you go home and you look in the mirror
and you say exactly what you want to do
and you commit to that
and what I'm hearing,
it could be different,
but what I'm hearing
is that you want to put
images into the marketplace
that are beautiful images of yoga
and then you want the
commercial relationship
with the yoga brand.
Have you tried that?
Do you believe that?
Have you said it over
and over and over again?
And all you need to get paid is--
- Well see my thing is--
- Hold tight.
- All you need to get
paid is by one of them.
- I did though.
- And then the next one that
calls, then you- okay, good.
- I did.
- When the next one--
- I did get one.
- When the next one calls, you
tell the next one that calls
that I just did a shoot with these guys
and it turned out great
and then you got a price.
And then you've done two.
And once you've done
two, you've done five,
and before you know it,
you're the fucking person
who does that for a living.
- Right, and that's the thing.
I'm at this point where
I love the photography.
I know this is it.
This is it.
But how am I gonna start getting that door
of the people coming into me
and it's like do I do the commercial?
- Patience.
- I know, honey.
I knew you were gonna tell me that.
(audience laughs)
- Well, listen.
Do you want me to tell you the bullshit?
Because there's a million
people doing that.
- No, I don't need the bullshit.
- Here's the real answer.
It's called fucking patience
and more importantly,
- Well, my thing was--
- Let me say something real quick.
- Okay, go ahead.
- It's about not being fancy.
In your situation right now,
if you want to put food on
the table, kids all that.
Get another job too.
Cool, you could.
You could sell stuff.
You could do something else.
What I'm even more scared about
is what happens in 18 months,
when you're rolling a little bit
and you start getting fancy.
I'm most scared in that
one year transition
where you went from the weddings
and now you're doing the yoga
and there's that one year
where you decided now you're fancy
and it starts breaking your behavior.
And you start acting like you're somebody.
- I think my biggest
question is me offering...
And I probably already do know the answer.
- You know all the answers.
- Yeah, it's all in there.
- You just want to hear it from us.
- I do.
- I actually do.
- I know.
- I know, but can I say
something real quick,
and this is for so many of you.
It's not that you want to hear it from us.
You're just still buying
time from eating shit.
(audience laughs)
People don't want to eat shit.
You guys don't want to eat shit.
Do you understand?
You know the answers.
You say you want to hear it from me.
You don't want to hear it from me.
You're still balking at
doing the fucking thing
that you don't want to do.
- I'm sure the answer is yes,
but is all of me still
going out and saying hey,
I'll shoot you for free.
Is that eventually
gonna lead to something?
- Maybe you suck shit at what you do.
(audience laughs)
- (laughing) I don't know.
- I'm being, like, I don't know.
I would hope so.
Under normal circumstances, yes,
but if you're the worst
photographer ever, no.
- Here's the thing.
Free or full price, never in the middle.
Think about that for a second.
Because free, whose terms is that shit on?
Yours.
Full price?
Who's getting paid?
You.
The middle, someone
says what's your price?
You say five grand.
They say I got 250.
You say yes to that, that's bad on you.
- You say I'll do it for free.
- Or...
- Or you need the 250.
No, Chase, I think it's an important-
- Money's money.
- Listen.
- Listen, you're right in
the philosophical standpoint,
but in our all realities, we
have an every day decision
and some days you have more
leverage than the others.
Really easy to be a big shot
when you have 11 people
wanting to give you dollars.
Much tougher to be cool
when it's the only person
that's reached out to you in three weeks,
which goes back to what I
care about most, patience.
You're trying to cash in on
good behavior six months in.
- You are.
- Listen to this and watch this backwards.
Hey, something good's starting to happen.
This is what I've been doing
for six or eight months.
Cool, now when do I get to the glory?
Never.
Invest in the process and
then you're fucking there.
If you love photography so much,
then this seems to be
fucking awesome, right?
You're trying to get to
the other side too quick
while you've already
figured out what it takes.
The end.
- I'm trying to figure it
out as I'm getting there
and I think that's where
I'm getting tangled.
- Keep eating shit.
- Okay, tastes good.
- And build your life.
- Organize your life so
that you can't eat shit.
I see people that have studios
and they're hiring people
and they're like what in the
fuck are you guys thinking?
- Getting fucking fancy around here.
- It comes from a good place,
but it's gonna create
a bad outcome for you.
- It's coming from a shit
place that's called insecurity.
You don't need shit to look cool.
- In the last six months,
I've actually condensed everything down.
I've gotten rid of a lot of expenses
and a lot of different things.
- That's how you win.
Doesn't matter how much money you make.
If you're wasting it, you're gonna lose.
- All right, you feel better?
- Yes.
- Round of applause for her, you guys.
(audience claps)
- Louder, that's a big deal
to get up here and be scared.
Of course, you got it.
- Thank you guys.
- Thank you.
I love this community.
- Humans, me too.
(audience laughs)
This is super human.
I've spent my time in every industry.
It's all the same shit.
It's all the same game.
But in the creative community,
there's this big backlash
against free work.
I do free work every day.
I make tens of millions of dollars a year.
The end.
Stop being so fucking fancy.
- Next victim?
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna go you right there.
Standing up against the post, you sir.
- And I mean that.
And I mean that in a really big way.
It makes me really sad 'cause
it's such a great craft
to have, but because you don't
have as much business sense,
you know, theoretically,
which is not true,
but often you start bashing
against the business part of this.
If you're such a fucking
artist, do it for free.
'cause when you start
charging, you're in business.
You better wrap your
fucking head around that.
And this is business dynamics.
You have a supply and demand issue.
There's an unlimited
amount of talent out there
and technology's caught up and has armed
every eight year old
with real fucking ammo.
Sorry.
Sorry, but that's what happened.
And until you fucking grasp
that and really get there,
sorry, but that's the reality.
So own it and go on the offense
instead of fucking sitting on your couch
and dwelling every day.
- Guys, let's welcome
Richard to the stage.
(audience claps)
- Thank you guys for picking me.
I appreciate it.
Gary, I've been doing the patience thing.
I've been podcasting for 11 years.
Content creating, lot of sleepless nights.
Haven't made a dime.
The thing is I want to support my family,
keep doing my nine to five.
And I've been doing it.
Posting on Instagram in
between my lunch breaks.
Writing posts for my site on
my phone, et cetera et cetera.
- [Gary] What do you want to happen?
Let's start there.
What's making it for you?
- All I want to do is review products,
write about video games and podcast.
- [Gary] And get paid.
- And get paid.
- How much have you reached out
to ask people for money for doing it?
- I've been reaching out here and there.
- Let's be really honest here.
Let's take advantage of this moment.
How many hours in the last 11 years,
and I'm asking you hours,
have you spent Emailing
Activision, Emailing Sony,
Emailing and saying I
would like you to pay me
to review this product.
- At least 50.
- [Gary] Hours.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] In 11 years?
- Probably a little more than that.
- Okay.
- Give or take.
- [Gary] And you've gotten mainly no's.
- Some yeses, but not consistent
and that's where the problem comes from.
It's playing the long
game, playing patient.
Doing a lot of free
content, giving it all away.
- And Richard, real quick for everybody.
There's unlimited stories like this.
It comes down to two variables.
Either A, you're not good enough
that the market wants to pay
because there's a lot
of reviews, which hurts.
Or B, which has been stunningly often,
you're not the person that
should be the business person.
You should be the creative.
What runs through my mind
is in your circle of life,
is there some homey that could
be your 50% business partner
where she or he may spend all the time
trying to monetize the creative
and 50 cents of a million
is a hell of a lot better
than zero of zero.
- One is better than zero,
like they always say.
- That's right.
- It's true.
- That's the thing.
I have people who have been helping me
on the site for years.
I built a podcast network from it,
doing shows for other guys,
other people that are on there
giving other people opportunities.
- Have you charged them?
Maybe you're a platform
that springs other talent
instead of being the talent.
Maybe you're a B to B business
instead of a B to C business.
- I haven't charged them
just because I was giving
people opportunities.
They started writing, they're like, hey,
I want to do the podcast thing like you.
I gave them the opportunity.
- [Gary] Have any of them
gone off and done real things?
- No, they're still grinding alongside me.
Some guys hit 100 shows
already, 200 shows, 500 shows.
That's the thing.
I feel like I'm spinning
my wheels a little bit.
- So if nobody was here,
and you were with yourself in the mirror,
it was that moment to say
why hasn't it happened?
What would be the answer, for real?
Don't bullshit me.
- I think it's just
spreading myself too thin,
more so than anything.
- So stop doing that.
- Have you tried doing--
- No, hold on.
- Chase, I apologize.
- Keep going.
- You just like being spread thin?
- No, it's not a question
of it's by choice.
It's because it's kinda forced.
- Everything's by choice, brother.
- I'll give you personal
context and I'll explain.
- Please.
- I've been raising my two sisters.
They're both handicapped.
I've been doing it for the last 17 years.
Both of them are special needs.
- Doing that.
- That's real.
- Juggling a nine to five job.
Being a husband, doing all that,
plus trying to grow a business,
spreading yourself thin.
I work a 40 hour workweek.
My wife spends most
time sleeping by herself
because I'm downstairs doing the grind.
Go to bed at 5 a.m., wake up at 9 a.m.
Go to work.
- Work 'til seven o'clock.
- Richard.
- That's what I mean.
- Richard, this is not fun for me to say,
but I want you to win.
- Appreciate it.
- There's a very fine line
between perseverance and delusion.
It's very thin.
11 years and your circumstance.
First of all, it sounds
like you can even tell,
you like what you're doing.
- I love what I do.
- Right, you might just
have to settle into that.
Because when I am auditing this,
and I don't know everything, right,
but even on quick intuition,
you might be better off
making money in some other way
that you're not seeing, but there's a love
to the consumer facing
output that you're making
that you may want to not let go of.
You might be able to make
80K at a B to B business
on what you're doing,
'cause it seems like you
have a lot of experience
and you could easily, pretty quickly,
start charging people $500 a month
teaching them 11 years of experience.
That's super valuable.
Times 80 people, it starts
becoming a real business.
You just might like the thrill
of putting out an output
into the world and I want to say this,
'cause we've done a lot of business talk.
It's funny for me 'cause
we're in a creative place.
In business world, I spend
all my time saying fuck money.
Make a little less and
do something you like,
'cause you're miserable.
You know how many people I know
make a million dollars a year
that fucking hate their lives?
A lot.
- Oh, I'm not greedy.
I just want to be able to make enough
to provide for my family.
- Respect.
- Live okay and just be a provider.
That's it.
Be able to provide value
for my audience while happy.
- I think you're putting your
talent in the wrong place.
I have a funny feeling.
You know my flip challenge.
I have a funny feeling
you'll make way more money
if you wake up at 6 a.m. on weekends
and go and garage sale and
flea market and goodwill stores
and buy underpriced
equipment in this industry
and flip it 'cause you actually know
the value of all this shit.
You're gonna have to make a choice
between happiness and dollars
because 11 years of data
are staring you in the face
saying what you're doing isn't working.
- Yeah, I mean, it's
growing, but it's you know.
Not a snail's pace, but not--
- 11 years is a long fucking time.
So you've gotta decide,
if you're not gonna be the personal brand,
like what do you want to do now?
Do you want to accept it
because the love is so awesome
or do you want to transfer
the skills and the knowledge
into something that's a
more monetizable reality?
And that's up to you.
There's no right answer.
Maybe those nights are a lot of fun.
I got lucky that business
savvy was my thing
but when I was getting D's and F's
and college was the only way out,
I got shit on my entire childhood,
'cause it wasn't good or cool.
But I chose it.
I was willing to be considered a loser
for up to 20 years old because
I just couldn't breathe
by not- the only thing
on earth I wanted to do
was buy and sell shit.
- I find people that
trip up on three things.
One of three things and I'm
borrowing from a friend,
Tony Robbins.
State, story, and strategy.
You usually are F'ed up on
one of these three things.
Mostly I find it's the state.
If you can't have control
of your state of mind.
If you're not healthy,
taking care of yourself,
in a good spot, it's very,
very hard for yourself
to tell yourself a good story,
because this is required.
I'm good enough, I'm enough,
it's who I am right now
to go out there and put the work.
I'm valuable.
I can do this.
These are stories.
And if you're story is this is impossible,
I'll never get there,
then you go back to state.
Fix the state first 'cause
you have to have a good state.
Tell yourself a good story.
When you get the story part
figured out, then the strategy.
I hear you oscillating a little bit
between story and strategy
'cause I hear a little bit
of I want to do this.
11 years, bro, is a lot.
Was it Nicole who was just up here?
Six months and she's getting impatient.
You've been doing it 11 years.
I love that.
It tells me you've got
a pretty good state.
Your story is good.
It's a little bit flimsy
because it's been 11 years now.
What I hear you not innovating
on is your strategy.
You're trying to do the same thing
and what Gary's telling you
is how can I make money?
Is it here?
is it here?
Am I charging people for my MCM?
Am I reselling the gear?
How can I make the living
or the life or at first,
just some money in that world?
It seems like you've
been doing the same thing
and that's, you know,--
- The money's there.
It's been small, like I said.
Just small here and there.
People want to buy ad space.
- Real quick Richard, that
means the money's not there.
- Right, it's not sustainable.
- Small money for 11 years is not--
- Start with that.
Start with that.
The money's there but it's small.
No it's not.
The money's not there to the
satisfaction that you want.
Some people want 50,000 a
year, some want 5 million.
The money's not there.
And that's okay.
Listen, being an entrepreneur
right now has tricked everybody.
It feels like anybody can do it.
It's super cool.
It's super hard to build
a successful business.
- Absolutely.
- It's super hard.
- It's an actual skill.
Like, the end.
It comes natural to
some, just like singing.
Just like having an eye for a photo.
I don't see a fucking
blue jay and be like,
oh, there's an angle
(imitates camera shutter).
(audience laughs)
I see a blue jay, I'm
like fuck that blue jay.
(audience laughs)
These are skills.
Richard, the data shows you
that from a business building standpoint,
you may not have that skill.
Maybe it's yet, maybe it's
ever, we don't know you.
But the definition of insanity
is doing the same shit
over and over and expecting
a different result.
You've gotta do something different, bro.
- Is this clear?
What are you taking away
from this conversation?
- Well, I think that I've
gone too wide, like Gary says.
I've got to go deeper on one aspect--
- Do you just have a lot of
creative, technical interests?
- Well, what's happening is
you're putting out podcasts,
I've been doing that.
Doing the YouTube thing.
Doing the Facebook thing.
Doing the Instagram thing.
- But the thing is are you making
a different video every day on YouTube,
one is about vacuum cleaners,
the other is about technology,
- The third one is--
- No, no, I stay in my lane.
- It's tech products,
games, video games, phones.
- Super saturated.
Unlimited supply.
Super competitive.
Do me a favor.
How much money on this side project
would you like to make in a year?
Don't bullshit me.
What would get you like, holy shit.
Not like, I'm fucking buying islands,
(audience laughs)
but like this really matters to me.
This extra 5K, 50, give me a number.
- As separate from my regular income?
- Correct.
The thing that would make
you say fuck, this made it.
- I'd like to at least
make $10,000 a month.
15,000, not being greedy, just enough.
- That's fucking greedy.
Let me help you understand
why that's greedy.
You said 10 to 15,000 on the side.
Do you understand where
120,000 to $180,000 a year
puts you in the scheme of 100%
of the people in America's income?
- Yeah, on a world scale.
- So you're being greedy.
- And I need people to understand that.
People don't get it, right?
It's a real number.
We need to define greedy.
If you're making six figures a year,
you're making a lot of money by standards.
And I know New York might have
different things than that,
but you have to wrap your head around.
I don't think we sit and
really understand the data.
$440,000 a year puts you
at the bottom of the 1%.
The top 1% of everybody
make 440,000 and up.
But everybody starts talking like,
"if I don't make a million."
We're not grounding ourselves.
Making $180,000 a year as a
side hustle is greedy as fuck.
(audience laughs)
I'm being serious.
Now, by the way, you're
entitled to be greedy.
Be greedy, my man, but I need you
to wrap your head around that first.
Look, I think that you have to understand,
you have to be in the sales
and business business,
not in the content business.
I have a feeling that you
have a very big interest
in all these things,
so it's a lot more fun
to make the content and do the content
than it is to run the business.
- Yeah, definitely more labor intensive.
- No, Not labor intensive.
It's what you like more.
- Brother, you know what I like to do?
Slip into everybody's
DM and business develop.
Let's making a fucking deal.
I make the content as the secondary thing.
I don't like that.
Why do you think I don't fucking edit
Niko or Babin or D-Rock?
I don't give a fuck about the lighting.
I give a shit about the
game, the hustle, selling,
biz-deving, bringing value,
understanding how it brings
back in brand, building a brand,
leveraging, strategizing, where
am I going, selling, doing,
sneaker drop, planet of the apps,
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh
business, business, business.
That's my hustle.
That's why I make money 'cause
I like the business part.
You might be making tremendous content.
You just don't have the
business chops, bro.
Get a fucking partner, Richard,
'cause you can't do it.
- Nope, definitely not.
- Round of applause for Richard.
(crowd claps)
- And there's nothing
wrong with that, man.
That's when you make that
mindset, then you fucking win.
Get the business partner.
- [Richard] You know what it is?
- It's like--
- what's the podcast?
- My podcast is the Variant Issue.
My website is RageWorks.net.
- We're gonna say it one more time.
- Feel free to check it out.
- RageWorks.net.
- One more time.
- RageWorks.net is the site,
and the podcast that I do
right now is the Variant Issue.
It's a comic book podcast,
but we have a full
podcast network of shows.
Sports, movies, video
games, we got it all.
- You're about to get 400 subscribers.
- Guys.
- Richard, Richard.
- Thanks, guys.
- You have to understand.
Richard, where are you from?
- Oh, here in New York City.
I'm from Queens.
- If I was his business partner
on his comic book podcast,
we would make a million dollars a year.
(audience laughs)
- I'm being serious.
- Do it!
I can't.
I got my own shit, fuck you guys.
(audience laughs)
You're welcome, brother.
- Thanks, man.
You guys, you know how
to get his attention.
- DM him.
- It's true.
- He's GaryVee pretty much
everywhere, with two E's.
I don't know why you did that, bud.
- Worst branding move of my career.
Two silent E's?
What the fuck?
(audience laughs)
He's Gary, I'm Chase.
We're out of time.
I want to say thank you guys
very much for coming out.
- [Woman] Join me in thanking them.
(audience claps)
- Give it up for him, come on.
- This guy.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Jordan really wants to
know your two cents.
Right, Jordan?
- What's your two cents?
(rock music)